he was the UK's pick to be the next head
of NATO
that's not to be but the defense
secretary still made headlines at a
summit of allies
speaking off camera to journalists he
said he told Ukraine the UK was not an
Amazon style delivery service for
weapons
Sky News asked the Ukrainian president
about the remarks Ben Wallace also had
some advice for Keith as you keep on
asking for more and more weapons and
support and that was that people want to
see gratitude
how do you respond to that do you think
you're not being grateful enough
I believe that we were always grateful
to the UK you know we were always
grateful to the prime minister or two
prime ministers and the Minister of
Defense because the people in the United
Kingdom have always supported Ukraine
we're grateful for this he asked his
defense minister to extend some words of
gratitude and you have to call him
place today
Ben Wallace wasn't being critical about
a lack of gratitude he was really making
the point that Ukraine needed to think
carefully about the political reality in
certain countries where there are people
that need persuading to keep up the
support
the Prime Minister seemed to distance
himself from the comments I know
president zolenski has repeatedly
expressed his gratitude to me and to the
British people and indeed other allies
as well he did it very movingly in
Parliament when he was in the UK earlier
this year welcome to you brother moose
great to have you here
Vladimir zelensky was welcomed by NATO
for the first time as an equal he wants
full membership but that's impossible
while Ukraine's at War
instead allies meeting in the Lithuanian
Capital rallied around with new pledges
of support
it's all right Unity would shattered at
the first testing he thought Democratic
leaders would be weak
but he thought wrong
it's why what Britain's defense
secretary says matters he's ultimately
warning about the very real risk of War
fatigue
and the need to stay strong debraham Sky
News Vilnius